all right since coba restrictions are  loosening the springs preserve  is back in business it's now open to the  public face coverings are required and  social distancing measures are in place  to keep employees and visitors safe  the areas that are open now are only our  outdoor areas so that includes  our botanical garden it includes our two  plus  mile trail system our trackless train  ride will be running  we also have outdoor animal exhibits  that people will be able to see all  right great make some family plans and  you can stop by anytime from nine to  four pm  but you do need to buy ticket ahead of  time because they are  timed tickets